this blue marble-like planet looks just
like Earth but only 5 seconds on this
hostile death orb would kill
you welcome to hd189733b
this planet is enormous even larger than
Jupiter and to keep comparing it to the
largest planet in our solar system it's
also entirely made of gas
that's why scientists classify hd189733b
as a hot Jupiter this planet is located
so close to its star that it completes
its orbit in just over 2
days yeah hd189733b
is 13 times closer to its Sun than
Mercury is to our sun and even though
its star is cooler than ours this fake
Earth is still way outside its star
system's habitable zone that means no
liquid water can exist on a planet's
surface just how this giant gous planet
developed so close to a star is still a
mystery one theory is that hd189733b
formed right next to it during the
star's earliest moments or it could have
developed further away to be pulled in
as the rest of the planetary system
formed but there's one thing we know for
sure a visit to hd189733b
would be a plunge into hell with no
chance of
Escape now even if you knew there wasn't
a single drop of liquid water on this
planet you'd have a hard time believing
it as you approached the giant blue
marble with an average daytime
temperature of nearly 1,00 ° C this
planet is twice as hot as Venus and
Venus is the hottest planet in our solar
system one of the reasons for this
intense heat is that the planet is tidy
locked to its star just like our own
moon is to Earth that means hd189733b
takes as much time to spin on its axis
as it does to revolve around the star so
one side of the planet is constantly in
dating light while the other side is
shrouded in darkness the inviting look
of this world doesn't come from its
oceans like it does here on Earth no
this hellish Planet gets its color from
clouds of molten silic
particles these particles scatter more
blue light than red making the planet
appear blue silica is the primary
ingredient in glass and you should bring
a heavy duty umbrella because you'd need
to take cover from what would
essentially be hot molten glass
rainstorms but that's not the only
danger you'd need to be ready to brace
yourself against the extremely powerful
winds that you'd find sweeping across
the planet with speeds up to 7,000
kmph these gusts are almost 30 times
stronger than even the most powerful
Category 5 hurricanes on earth compared
to the strongest winds on other planets
in our solar system hd's winds are
almost four times stronger than those on
Neptune but hey they might smell a
little better than the ice giants
hydrogen sulfide clouds those carry a
whiff of rotten
eggs hdd's winds are so fast that they'd
whip past you at about six times faster
than the speed of sound they would be
extremely loud but I think you'd be more
worried about them tearing your body
apart you might be long gone by now
killed by that molten glass
rain in any case you wouldn't last too
long on hd189733b
I really don't recommend traveling
there but there are some planets out
there that can kill you even
faster check out Ogle
t56b this gas giant sits in a galaxy
nearly 100 light years away from Earth
it's even larger than HD its mass is
nearly 1.4 times as much as Jupiter's
and somehow it's even closer to its star
too you'd find this world to be
incredibly scorching hot surface
temperatures on this planet average
around 1700°
C that's so hot that it turns metal to
gas
ass of all the planets in the universe
Earth is clearly the best for life
right wrong Earth may be great but
scientists have discovered a few worlds
that could be even better for
Life behold Ki 5715
5.01 most of the contenders on our super
habitable planet list aren't the ones
you could visit anytime soon they are
very far away the top spot is held by
one 3,000 light years away from our
solar
system koi
5751 would appear to satisfy the most
basic requirement for supporting life it
exists in the gold loock zone of its
star so conditions wouldn't be too hot
or too cold for a key life supporting
ingredient to exist on its surface
liquid water but it would also check off
many boxes to be considered super
habitable the planetary system it
belongs to could be 52 billion years old
which would make it around 1 billion
years older than our own solar system
and the planet would almost fit the size
requirement when looking for
superhabitable worlds scientists keep
their eyes peeled for planets that have
a mass up to 1 and 1 half times of our
planet and they should be about 10%
larger too this size difference would
help the planet retain heat and if its
average temperature was about 5° C
higher than Earth's well this planet
could have even richer
biodiversity now being almost double the
size of Earth koi
[Music]
well we're just getting
started approximately 2700 light years
away is Kepler
69c this super Earth could be around 7
billion years old this puts it perfectly
in the estimated 5 to 8 billion year old
age range for superhabitable planets
this range is based on the 3 and a half
billion years it took for complex life
to appear on Earth
so the best chance for finding life
could be on a planet a little older than
us only this exoplanet could be a little
too big to be super habitable it has a
mass almost four times that of Earth a
rocky planet this big could have a
single colossal continent that would
have huge deserts in its Center but the
coastline Washed by Kepler's ocean could
be your perfect spot to move
to
our next Super Earth shares a similar
name Kepler
1126b except it would be located ever so
slightly closer to home yeah this planet
is about
273 light years away and it belongs to a
system that is 7 and A2 billion years
old it also orbits a yellow dwarf star
much like our own only Kepler 1126b is 2
and a half times closer to its star than
Earth is to the Sun but that's no big
deal because the star Kepler 1126b
orbits is cooler than ours so the
habitable zone would exist in a Range
much closer in proximity to
it if you aren't feeling this nearness
to a scorching hot star there's another
Super Earth on our list and it's at a
reasonable distance from home
speculo 2C is located only 106 Lighty
years away not that its proximity gives
it any kind of Advantage it would still
take you well over
2,000 years to travel to this super
Earth and that's if you moved at the
speed of NASA's Parker solar probe the
fastest probe ever
launched speculo 2C does look promising
though it's about 40% larger than Earth
there's also the potential for it being
a rocky planet just like ours now
despite the fact that it also exists in
the habitable zone its red dwarf star is
still very small it's only about 15% the
size of our sun so this planet orbits
around its star at a very close distance
and this close distance could mean that
speculo 2C is tidally locked to its
star this super Earth takes 8 and 1/2
days to make one full rotation on its
axis as well as one orbit around its
star that would leave one side of the
planet in constant daylight and the
other in Endless Night this means that
life could be possible in The Terminator
Zone the thin strip of land between the
two sides we just need to get a better
look to find out for
sure you know of all those planets I'd
be most interested in exploring speculo
I imagine it smells like gingerbread and
cinnamon and it tastes delicious my
Belgian friends know speculo is a famous
cookie originating in Belgium but this
planet wasn't named after the cookie
it's actually named by Belgian
astronomers after the speculo planet
hunting telescopes in this case speculo
is an acronym for search for habitable
planets eclipsing Ultra Cool
Stars okay more Great Space discoveries
ahead including a look at the Bermuda
Triangle of space But first I've got
something even scarier than that the
closest black hole to Earth At least
that we know of black holes are dark
matter devouring balls of gravity most
of them are so far away that we don't
need to worry about them but not this
one meet Gaia
bh1 this enormous black hole sits right
outside our solar
system more specifically 1,600 light
years away from us now that might sound
like a huge distance but it's way closer
than any other black hole on record
what's worse we didn't even know about
it until now
despite Gaia bh1 being 10 times more
massive than our son we couldn't see it
scientists usually discover these
monstrosities by spotting the gas that a
black hole feeds on these hungry Giants
are called feeding black holes only Gaia
bh1 isn't anything like that this black
hole is dormant it hides in the Darkness
patiently waiting for the Galaxy to
throw at some Cosmic matter to Feast on
but there's one thing that gave away
gaia's presence you see most star
systems in the universe are binary that
means they have not one but two stars
orbiting each other our black hole
neighbor is also part of a binary star
system except instead of two stars this
system has one star and one black
hole Yeah Gaia bh1 was disguising itself
as a star but even though this
monstrosity doesn't feed on any gas or
matter yet it still couldn't help but
jiggle its star counterpart a little
yeah good try Gaia but we still caught
you out there in space there are black
holes a lot scarier than Gaia
H1 and some are so bizarre that they
shouldn't even exist a team of
scientists discovered an unbelievable
black hole and gave it the melodic name
lb1 the weird thing about this black
hole is that it's just too massive to be
true okay let's get some facts straight
we know of two types of black holes
Stellar black hole BS are what massive
stars become when they die they're
everywhere in the universe Even in our
Milky Way galaxy there could be as many
as 1 billion of them lurking around
these beasts can be between 10 and 24
times as massive as our
sun the other type of black holes are
super massive ones these enormities sit
at the center of almost every Galaxy
including our own we don't really know
how they form but we do know that
they're unimaginably gigantic billions
of times more massive than our
sun but lb1 doesn't fit either of these
types at 70 solar masses it's too
enormous to be a stellar black hole yet
it's too tiny to be a super massive one
scientists were scratching their heads
trying to explain this
phenomenon some theorized that it might
not be a single black hole but two black
holes orbiting each other others guessed
that lb1 was born of a gigantic star
that was still in the middle of becoming
a black
hole well the answer was simpler than we
thought lb1 isn't a black hole at all
it's an optical illusion caused by two
rare Stu Stars orbiting each other it's
a unique star system to
stargaze but when scientists said they
found an improbable black hole well they
were wrong but please how could you
blame them it's pretty hard to study an
object
15,000 light years away mistakes happen
the good news is that lb1 didn't upend
our understanding of black holes after
all now that doesn't mean that black
holes can't blow your mind remember the
one at the center of the Milky Way yeah
it's called Sagittarius A star and it's
as massive as 4 and2 Million
Suns but there's always a bigger fish in
the universe Sagittarius A star might be
the most massive monster lurking in our
galaxy but it's not even close to some
of the really big players out there like
ton
618 this black hole is devouring matter
10 billion light years away from us it's
as bright as 140 trillion Suns so bright
that it outshines its own Galaxy and its
mass yeah 66 billion times that of our
sun yeah that's right 66 billion ton 618
is horrifyingly
big when scientists discovered it they
began to wonder if even more massive
black holes were possible of course the
name super massive wouldn't do bigger
black holes any justice so astronomers
came up with a cool name for them too
stupendously large black holes or
slabs yeah and then they found one move
over ton 618 there's a new gargantuan
black hole in
town this stupendously large monstrosity
sits at the center of Phoenix a Galaxy
around 8 and A2 billion light years away
from
us it's almost impossible to imagine how
enormous this thing is scientists think
it has a mass of 100 billion
Suns that's more massive than some
galaxies out there and it won't stop
growing The Event Horizon of this black
hole at the center of Phoenix a is
unimaginably huge too it has a diameter
of about 100 times the distance between
the Sun and Pluto if you jumped on a
SpaceX Starship and tried to fly across
this black hole it would take you
2500 years to complete that Journey
yeah we're lucky that this monstrous
slab is so far away from us that we
don't have to worry about it swallowing
our solar system
whole but there are two more super
massive black holes very close to Earth
and they're on a collision course with
each other okay when I say very close to
Earth I mean 500 million light years
away from us but still closer than a lot
of the other scary things out there
seriously though we don't know what
exactly happens when two super massive
black holes Collide we've never observed
a full merger of super massive Giants
scientists think that they'll dance
around each other for about 200 million
years before finally becoming
one but this would be a violent marriage
as the black holes spiral together
they'll send enormous gravitational
waves through space waves so big that
we'll be able to detect them from our
planetary
neighborhood but that's not the scary
part mergers like that happen all the
time and right now the Milky Way is on a
collision course with the Andromeda
galaxy when our two galaxies become one
what will happen to the super massive
black holes at their
centers will they merge too would an
event like this tear everything in its
vicinity to
shreds yeah I bet that's what keeps
astronomers up at
[Music]
night just north of the Martian equator
lies a 4 5 km wide impact crater that
scientists believe may have been the
sight of an ancient Lake here at jazero
Crater scientists theorize that its
frozen soil may contain the most
significant discovery of
humankind
life on February 18th
2021 NASA's perseverance Rover started
searching this crater
to find out if we're truly
alone what is the likelihood of Life on
Mars what would these Martians look
like and how will we send samples back
to
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if we discovered Life on
Mars as Scientific American puts it it
would take a near miracle for Mars to be
sterile astrobiologist Chris McKay at
Nasa believes that Earth and Mars have
been sharing materials for billions of
years kind of like using your roommates
spice rack what I thought you said it
was
communal comets or large meteorites that
have hit Earth may have also sent debris
onto Mars a tiny fraction of this debris
on Mars could have carried the same
microbes that kickstarted Life as we
know it on Earth but what would this
alien life look
like many scientists agree that whatever
life on Mars we might find would need to
be incredibly robust with the
combination of radiation and freezing
temperatures on Mars could any life form
survive such a harsh
environment as far-fetched as it sounds
microbiologists have discovered many
organisms that thrive in extreme
environments the tardigrade or water
bear is a highly resistant
extremophile it can withstand heat cold
pressure radiation and even a complete
lack of
oxygen there are also certain types of
bacteria on Earth that rapidly produce
spores when faced with hazardous
conditions the bacteria can then
hibernate during an extended period of
drought and withstand intense ionizing
radiation a team of 1,000 geologists
chemists physicists and biologists
worldwide have drilled 4.8 km into the
Earth and discovered robust life forms
Mars has a similar geological past to
Earth so looking underground could be a
great place to
start by drilling into the jazero crater
we we could encounter spores associated
with a relatively recent geological era
and on future missions to Mars we may
dig deeper and uncover fully vegetative
microbes to find rock samples that might
support life NASA's perseverance Rover
uses an array of lasers called a super
cam it can study the surface of Mars at
a distance one of the lasers will heat a
rock sample and vaporize it this creates
a plasma that can be analyzed to
understand its Elemental composition
another laser will reveal which
compounds are in the dirt if the super
cam detects organic molecules or
elevated concentrations of elements like
nitrogen or phosphorus the Rover will
head over to take a closer look it will
then scan the soil in Greater detail to
detect any organic material hiding in
the dirt
NASA's team on Earth has only one shot
at picking the right spot to gather
these samples with limited space on
board the Rover only a few dozen samples
can be collected so no pressure and
fingers
crossed if all goes well NASA plans to
bring back samples known for preserving
bio signatures on Earth bios signatures
are faint molecular traces left behind
by microbes billions of years ago once
the samples are collected NASA and the
European Space Agency plan two missions
to get them back to Earth this involves
blasting tubes of rock and soil samples
into orbit to be collected by another
spacecraft and then returned to Earth W
this looks kind of
fun if perseverance mission is
successful the discovery of Life on Mars
would be be as groundbreaking as the
discovery of
DNA in
1543 Copernicus boldly shook the status
quo with his theory that the planets
orbited the sun his discoveries
completely changed our worldview no
longer putting Earth at the center of
the
universe discovering life beyond Earth
could be just as
powerful but not finding any life could
raise more questions is the earth truly
special are we alone out
here even if we don't discover Life
these Martian Rock samples will allow
chemists to study the geochemistry
minerology and foundational Bedrock
materials of Mars in
detail this could provide us with
essential insights into the climate
history of Mars and help us better
understand earth's climate as
well in 19 1976 two Viking Landers
became the first spacecrafts from Earth
to touch down on Mars they too probed
for life in the Martian soil and the
results are still debated to this day
one experiment indicated that the
Martian soil tested positive for
metabolism on Earth this would almost
certainly suggest the presence of life
but another related experiment found no
trace of organic material
whatsoever While most scientists have
not reconciled the conflicting results
the consensus is that there's no
conclusive evidence of Life on Mars but
several researchers disagree recent
discoveries of terrestrial
microorganisms surviving outside of the
ISS indicate that life may be resilient
enough for Mars and methane in the
Martian atmosphere could be a sign of
microb Ral methanogens a type of
microorganism that produces a
significant amount of methane stinky
aliens mind you it's possible that life
on Mars didn't have the right conditions
to start at all or maybe it died off
from an Extinction event similar to the
asteroid that wiped out the dinosaurs or
it's even possible that we might end up
finding life that was accidentally
brought to Mars by one of our many
Rovers let's hope this perseverance
Mission doesn't turn into a $2.7 billion
face
palm if Mars is your bag well have you
ever thought about setting up shop there
with recent developments in rocketry
colonizing Mars might be possible In Our
Lifetime okay colonizing Mars sounds
like a fun idea but in reality would you
really want to move there I wouldn't
consider it a Spare Earth it's pretty
inhospitable now it's possible we could
make it habitable but if we have that
kind of capability why don't we look at
something else in the universe that's a
little more people friendly well later
on we'll explore one possible friendly
candidate Kepler 22b but it's 635 light
years away you want to make that move
I'm happy to move if the planet has
beaches and Long Summers and waterfalls
and mangoes but unless this planet is
better than Earth I say we stay right
here watch
[Music]
this could there be an even better
planet for us than
earth scientists are searching for a
super habitable world that wouldn't just
rival Earth but be a place where life
could Thrive even more easily and
they're looking at exoplanets
how would we discover earth
2.0 what would make an exoplanet
habitable and how long would it take to
get
there this is what if and here's what
would happen if we discovered Earth
2.0 you wouldn't be able to find an
exoplanet by looking through a telescope
all you'd see is the bright glare of the
Stars they orbit NASA built the Kepler
Telescope to discover exoplanets and
before it ran out of fuel the Kepler
Telescope surveyed our region of the
Milky Way galaxy its technology uses the
transit method to find planets hundreds
of light years away how it measured the
fluctuation of light coming from distant
Stars when a planet transits or passes
in front of a star the star isn't as
right so the Kepler telescope uses that
to detect
exoplanets this is not an easy thing to
do but during its 9-year lifetime the
Kepler Telescope confirmed the existence
of
4,367
exoplanets could any of them be Earth
2.0 if you're a longtime fan of what if
you've probably heard this before but
Earth is a very special place
and even if a planet is deemed to be
habitable it doesn't mean that it
resembles Earth very much a habitable
planet is a rocky planet located in the
habitable zone allowing water to stay on
the planet's surface in its liquid form
that's it Venus and Mars are habitable
planets but they are definitely not like
Earth so let's talk about three major
conditions that we'd look for when
searching for an even better version of
Earth First it would need to have
sunlight our Sun's lifespan is about 10
billion years and it took 4 billion
years for anything more complex than the
simplest life form to pop up on our
planet but k type dwarf stars have
lifespans of about 70 billion years so
if we found an exoplanet orbit a k type
star there would be more time for life
to evolve and live on it the second
major condition is temperature a planet
that's too hot or too cold wouldn't be
able to host the life forms we'd need to
survive but if we find a Planet that's a
mere 5° warmer than Earth and it has
more water we could be looking at Earth
2.0 covered in a lush biodiverse
rainforest
the third major condition we'd be
looking for is
size gravity retains a planet's
atmosphere and there's a direct
relationship between gravity and a
planet's size so if we find a Planet
that's only one in a half times larger
than Earth it would be able to hold on
to its interior heat and maintain its
atmosphere for a longer
time but bigger isn't always better
while Earth sized exoplanets are usually
Rocky about 50% of the exoplanets larger
than Earth are gas giants and if an
exoplanet is too small it would likely
be Barren like Mars so are there any
exoplanets out there that meet these
requirements okay I found a planet that
could be super habitable Kepler
1649c could be a contender to become
Earth Earth
2.0 it's 300 light years away and orbits
a red dwarf star it gets sunlight but
only 75% as much as Earth so it might be
a bit cooler there and there wouldn't be
any seasons on Kepler
1649c a full orbit only takes 19 and 1
half Earth days so we'd need to get used
to that oh and it could be tidy locked
which means one side of the planet
constantly faces its sun while the other
side faces
space Also living on a planet that
orbits a red dwarf star could be
risky sometimes red dwarf stars send out
massive flares dousing an orbiting
planet in UV light and creating huge
temperature
fluctuations but if we decide that
Kepler
1649c is worthy of becoming Earth 2. .0
what would happen
next well using our current technology
it would take at least 2,000 years to
reach this Earth 2.0 and since this
planet is so far away we only know about
its size the distance to its star and
the makeup of its
atmosphere so we could pack up humanity
take the multi-generational trip to
Earth 2.0 and discover that it's more
like a Neptune
2.0 uh yeah there's no way we could
survive on a gas giant we need much more
information before we send humans to any
possible Earth
2.0's so right now NASA is developing a
tiny probe to travel at 1 of the speed
of light it could greatly expand our
knowledge of
exoplanets and we shouldn't limit
ourselves to looking just at
exoplanets a moon receives direct solar
energy from its star and the planet it
orbits reflects solar energy toward it
so maybe a moon could be more suitable
for human life than an exoplanet the
most earthlike planet in our solar
system is Titan Saturn's largest moon so
if we want to save thousands of years of
traveling maybe Titan could make a good
second home for us Rockets are
incredibly powerful you can launch
yourself into orbit fly the moon and
soon enough travel to Mars but to go
beyond our solar system you're going to
need something else solar
sails how exactly would sails work out
in
space how long would it take you to
travel to the edge of the solar
system and why could this journey end
with your slow and lonely
demise this is what if and here's what
would happen if you sailed the Galaxy on
solar
winds to launch a spaceship you need a
rocket to push you up into the sky that
push is called thrust being launched
from Earth with the power of a rocket
gives a spacecraft most of its momentum
after this you'd need more fuel to
change your speed or course but there
are no gas stations out there in space
for you to refuel and that means you can
only go as far as your fuel takes you
you see more fuel means more weight and
in space your reserves are limited in
other words it would be really hard to
get to your Interstellar destination
with rockets
alone but all of that is about about to
change all aboard you're set to sail
across the
Galaxy on Earth sails have been moving
boats around the globe for centuries
they work without any fuel only the
power of wind but out in space there are
no air particles moving around so you'd
need to harness a different kind of wind
solar winds carry charged particles
ejected by the sun these particles fly
across the solar system at a
blisteringly fast 1.6 million
kmph but with a special type of sail you
could take advantage of that power to
get yourself across the solar system and
beyond and no those special sails
wouldn't look much like the sails you're
familiar with are you ready to have your
mind blown this is the contraption that
could take you across the Galaxy it's
called electric sails or E sails they're
kind of like an umbrella without fabric
only these ribs would be made of
electrically charged aluminum wires and
they can be as long as 20 km while also
being no thicker than about half of one
strand of hair upon your head now all
you'd need is the solar wind and you
could sail across the deep dark SE of
outer
space wait wait wait wait um there's one
catch you see you'd still need chemical
Rockets to launch you off into space to
begin with that's because electric sails
don't work within Earth's
magnetosphere the magnetosphere is the
area around the planet that's under the
influence of its magnetic field it's up
to 10 times larger than Earth itself and
to escape it you'd need a little boost
from the old school Rockets or you could
build a space port around Earth it would
have to be far enough so that the
planet's magnetic field doesn't reach it
but you know that would get too
expensive and take too long to construct
and we want to send you on this journey
right now so you'd launch your ship from
Earth and out of the magnetosphere
limits from there a it would be smooth
sailing with a 1,000 kg spacecraft like
yours you'd have about 100 wires to
catch solar wind particles you'd be a
Pioneer voyaging through space with this
fantastic new
technology after 1 year of sailing you'd
reach a speed of at least 30 km/ second
and you might even go as fast as 150 50
km/s and that's really fast faster than
Voyager 1 the fastest space probe humans
have ever sent off world the Voyager 1
probe is hurdling through space at about
km/s after spending 3 years getting past
Mars Jupiter Saturn and Uranus you'd end
up beyond the orbit of Neptune you'd
navigate by simply changing the voltage
levels on different wires of your
electric sails yeah well you'd still
have to be a navigational genius to sail
safely especially when you get closer to
the outer edges of the solar system here
you have to pass through the Kyper
belt this area is filled with icy comets
and if you're not careful these comets
will do some Hefty damage to your
electric sails yeah your Interstellar
trip might end before you even get out
of our planetary
neighborhood after that you've still got
a long way to go to the very end of the
solar system the
heliopause it's four times further away
from the Sun than
Neptune so fasten your seat belts and
power through a pretty uneventful view
for about 10 more years yeah I know I
know you'd prefer a view of Jupiter or
Uranus instead but hey it's almost time
to explore worlds you've never
seen ooh ah I just remembered I was
supposed to tell you something
important yeah you know how your
electric sails need solar winds to
sail well uh now you'd be the furthest
from the Sun you've ever been and that
means there won't be as many solar
particles pushing your spaceship
forward your sailing might just come to
a complete stop leaving you stuck
forever in the outskirts of the solar
system cold lonely and
hopeless yeah I'm not going to lie this
could be how your days come to an end so
while you still have some life left in
your sales you'll need to navigate to
another star if I were you I'd head to
the alpha centor star system it's the
closest one around and it has not one
but three
stars now you should also know that not
all stars are equal in providing you the
powerful solar winds you so desperately
need passing by a red dwarf star like
Alpha centor C also known as Proxima
centory you'd experience luminosities
that could be anywhere from 110th to
1,000th as strong as our own Sun but
despite this you might be able to gain
enough accelerating power to reach super
high speeds once again and all this
without any chemical fuel yeah going
green is the cool new thing everyone's
talking about yeah sailing across the
universe is fun until the solar wind
dies down most Earth Sailors will have a
propeller as a backup but just make sure
it's not a combustion engine because
there's no oxygen in space hey you like
my shirt well you can have one of your
own you know we got a merch store don't
you you didn't know well check out
what's in it by going to shop.
underknown
docomo the wha if 100 hats hoodies and
more we've got it all all right one of
the spookiest places on our planet used
to be the Bermuda Triangle but over the
last few decades people have lost
interest in it so now there's a new more
mysterious triangle bigger and better
than before and it's in space Did you
know that there's a mysterious area in
space where astronauts are unable to
communicate with home base they're
exposed to extreme levels of radiation
and their spaceships start to
malfunction it's being dubbed the
Bermuda Triangle of space this area has
perplexed scientists for decades but
astronomers may have finally solved this
outer space
anomaly what exactly is the Bermuda
Triangle of space anyway well its
official name is the South Atlantic
anomaly or SAA for short it's hovering
above the South Atlantic stretching from
Chile to Zimbabwe and this area has a
considerably weaker magnetic field when
compared to the rest of the Van Allen
radiation belt the Van Allen radi ration
belt is a pair of cosmic Donuts
surrounding Earth this is a unique
location where the radiation belt comes
closest to the Earth's surface these
belts trap particles that shoot from the
sun which protects the Earth from
harmful radiation the solar radiation
within the South Atlantic anomaly isn't
held back to the same degree though but
why well to explain that first let's
dive into what happens if you wander
into this terrifying part of our solar
system the SAA is known for causing
electronic malfunctions in spaceships
and extreme radiation exposure for
astronauts it can completely destroy
spacecraft in 2016 the Japanese
satellite Hitomi Came Crashing Down to
Earth after satellite operators began
getting mixed signals from the ship it
was reporting inaccurate data about how
it was performing up in space making
people down on Earth think that
everything was fine but this was
happening as it traveled through the SAA
so operators weren't aware that there
was a problem and couldn't take steps to
correct it the Hubble telescope luckily
has managed to avoid any issues while
traveling through the SAA that's despite
spending a whopping 15% of its time in
the space anomaly to protect the
telescope satellite operators power it
down if they didn't the SAA could
corrupt any precious data that's being
collected and potentially crash but how
do astronauts deal with these heavy
levels of radiation
well their radiation levels are
constantly being monitored so if they do
end up in the anomaly they have what's
known as a water wall certain rooms on
ships are filled with these massive bags
of water and if you stand behind them
they'll protect you from radiation water
is the best thing to Shield you from
this harmful energy because of its high
hydrogen content now if they didn't have
this water wall they could get severe
radiation poisoning or even cancer so we
know know the radiation levels are much
higher and more dangerous in this
specific part of space but why is it
happening in the first place well
despite what pictures might show you
Earth isn't completely round it bulges
around the center like me and because of
this the Earth's physical Center and its
magnetic Center are slightly off by
about 500 kmet this offset means things
like cosmic rays can get closer to the
Earth's surface near the bulging area
luckily the Earth's magnetic bubble can
still keep all those dangerous rays from
getting to us but that's not the case
for people in space above the South
Atlantic because of this stronger
radiation levels can reach this point up
in space and what's even more concerning
due to the fact that the magnetic poles
here on Earth are constantly changing
the South Atlantic anomaly keeps growing
it's also gotten weaker by 15% meaning
the radiation has has gotten stronger in
the area so NASA has been carefully
monitoring the SAA since 2019 they've
noticed that the anomaly is moving West
and what's even weirder the anomaly is
also splitting in two if this continues
it could make things even more
complicated regarding space travel and
data collection but luckily for it to
change significantly would take Millions
if not billions of
years so this Bermuda Triangle of space
isn't as mysterious as it sounds and
astronomers are getting better at
handling it with every new ship launch
and every piece of data
[Music]
recorded
635 light years from where you are
sitting way out there in outer space
lies a planet the first planet to be
discovered within the habitable zone of
a sunlike
star its name is Kepler
22b when a planet is located within a
star's habitable zone it means there is
a chance that liquid water exists on its
surface and where there's water there's
also the possibility of life human
life how long would it take to get to
Kepler 22b
what would the weather be like over
there and why would you need to get
jacked before arriving on this new
planet this is what if and here's what
would happen if you live on Kepler
22b Kepler 22b is what scientists call
an exoplanet it's a planet outside our
solar system spotting an exoplanet like
Kepler 20 to be is often not easy the
bright glare of the Stars they orbit
tends to keep them hidden from our
telescopes what did scientists come up
with to get around
in looking at the stars themselves to
see if they can find anything unusual
about them they spotted Kepler 22b using
What's called the transit method they
watched Kepler 22 the star this
exoplanet orbits around and noticed that
its brightness changes over time that
was because Kepler 22b was blocking the
Stars light with this scientists were
able to learn both the size of 22b and
how it orbits and it looks like this
distant Space Rock could become our next
home okay but what do we really know
about Kepler
22b its mass is 36 times that of Earth
with a radius of 2 and 1/2 times larger
than ours one year on Kepler 22b is 290
days it's also located 15% closer to its
star than we are to the
sun if Earth scooched over that close to
our
star you'd be fried Kepler 22b on the
other hand is lucky to have a sun that
is remarkably similar to ours but also
smaller and cooler this close proximity
to its star allows the planet to receive
about the same amount of sunlight as we
get over here the temperature on Kepler
22b could be about 15 to 22° C similar
to Earth's Spring weather and quite
habitable if you ask
me but our galaxy can be a cruel place
and not everything is good
news some models suggest Kepler 22b is
rotating on its side kind of like our
very own
Uranus this may sound insignificant but
it adds potentially deadly
complications this would mean that its
North and South poles are shrouded in
either Darkness or sunlight for half a
year and this ain't simply a matter of
whether you're a daytime or a nighttime
person a world like Kepler 22b spinning
on its side means that temperatures
could change from boiling to
freezing which wouldn't be great for
human
life I know what a bummer but don't
despair yet because our galaxy is also
big enough to include some hope new
studies suggest that Kepler 22b might be
covered in an ocean 50 m deep and that
ocean would be able to act as natural
climate control keeping the wild
temperatures at Bay you see an ocean can
store heat in the summer and release it
during the winter which results in a
mild climate like you needed another
reason to live close to the
water but hold on how would you even
make it all the way to Kepler
22b I mean even if you were traveling at
the speed of light it would take you
years your best bet could be to
hibernate through the trip inside a
device that preserves your body way past
its natural lifespan like cryogenic
sleep NASA has already developed a
cryosleep chamber that can lower an
astronaut's body temperature to as low
as 32°
C this would trigger natural hibernation
during which catheters would provide
your body with nutrients and remove any
waste
but even in cryo sleep it would be quite
the long risky trip this leads us to the
most dangerous part about this journey
All That Remains Unknown about Kepler
22b for starters we still don't really
know what gravity is like there it could
be twice as strong as our planets if
that was the case a 10 kg sack of
potatoes would now weigh 20 kg
and your body would also factor into the
mix is your current weight 75 Kg well
good luck suddenly dealing with 150 kg
of you and just for safety settlers such
as yourself would need to bulk up really
bulk up only through intense strength
training would you increase your chances
of being able to walk on Kepler
22b and once you got jacked on Earth
you'd have to figure out ways to
preserve that muscle through all
635 years of light speed
travel but humans aren't the only life
form that would be affected by a
stronger gravity plants brought from
Earth for oxygen and nutrition might not
survive on Kepler 22b when you try
growing them there and if you brought
any animals with you they'd need to step
up the evolution process higher gravity
could lead to creatures developing
additional legs to move around it could
also determine the location and size of
internal
organs but the Mysteries don't end there
scientists still don't know for sure
that Kepler 22b is even a rocky planet
it might be gous similar to Neptune or
it could be entirely covered with water
if you and the other first first
settlers woke up from your cry sleep and
found yourself on a gas planet yeah that
would be a downer you wouldn't have a
solid surface to even land your ship not
to mention a place to set up camp in
that case you and your crew would need
to figure out how to build a cloud city
orbiting the planet if you landed on an
ocean planet a submarine town would be
in
order discovering Kepler 22 B is a rocky
planet would be hitting the jackpot then
right well not so fast Venus is also
made of rock and yet its dense
atmosphere consisting of greenhouse
gases makes it uninhabitable with
scorching temperatures far too hot for
liquid water if this was also the
situation with Kepler 22b our only
chance at thriving on this exoplanet
would be to employ robots watch that
could build underground shelters the
place where maybe just maybe the
temperature might be cool enough for you
to
Bear it just goes to show you that a
prime location is no guarantee for human
survival and as exciting as it might
seem to find other worlds to inhabit our
own Earth Remains the perfect Habitat
for Humanity but sometimes the slight
slightest change can shake its Ideal
Balance just turn off the oxygen supply
for 5 seconds and a raging sunburn is in
the cards for you but that's a story for
another what
if okay well we've come to the end
thanks for joining us here on our
stunningly Stupify swing through space I
hope you learned something I know I did
it's let's take care care of the planet
we have so that we don't have to leave
and colonize some ball of rocks 200
parex away but that's a story for
another what
if this Blue Marble likee planet looks
just like Earth but only 5 seconds on
this hostile death orb would kill
you welcome to HD
189733b